imagine having so many children you
could run a factory that's what moulay
ismaïl x' family looked like he was a
brutal Emperor of the Moroccan Alawis
dynasty from 1670 to to 1727 and he was
reported to have had at least
1171 children but he wasn't the only one
who used his power to sleep with
hundreds of women whether they were
interested or not other rulers like
Augustus the strong and Genghis Khan had
hundreds of children and while these
were some of the more ruthless rulers of
their time it raises a more fundamental
scientific question women can reproduce
for about half their lifetime and can
only give birth about once every year or
so so it makes sense that women can only
have a fraction as many children as men
one study estimated that women can have
around fifteen pregnancies in a lifetime
and depending on how many babies she
gives birth to at a time a woman can
probably have around 15 to 30 children
max but the most prolific mother ever
according to Guinness World Records was
Miss Fyodor Vasily F in 19th century
Russia she said to have given birth to
69 children over 27 pregnancies that's a
lot for one woman but that's nothing
compared to our French from earlier
moulay ismaïl according to records he
had four wives and 500 women in his
harem but there are factors that not
even an emperor can control like how a
man's sperm becomes less mobile and more
abnormal as he grows older which
ultimately reduces his chances of
fathering children later in life in fact
studies suggest that men over 50 have an
up to 38 percent lower chance of
impregnating a woman compared to men
under 30 for Ishmael he fathered most of
his children relatively young so by age
57 he had an estimated 1171 kids but he
wasn't the only man in history with tons
of progeny
I guess this the strong was king of 18th
century Poland and he had a
long-distance relationship with his wife
hmm
so of course that didn't stop him from
fathering a rumored three hundred and
seventy children by mistresses and
Genghis Khan notorious for conquering
large areas of 13th century Asia is
estimated to have had between 1,000 and
2,000 children in fact by tracking types
of y-chromosomes scientists estimate
that up to 16 million men today who live
in regions that kong conquered could
have been descendants of him or his
close male relatives but these men
really reached their maximum human
possibility
turns out the records on Ismail only
spanned 32 years of his life by one
calculation he really could have had
hundreds more if you compare that to men
in more modern times the most prolific
fathers today have about 200 children
that's nowhere near 1171 and honestly
it's probably for the best